most important story of the day I think
here is the New York
Post um it's official The Elf on the
Shelf trend has gone too far keeping
kids entertained during the festive
season can be tough and just like many
other parents mom of two CeCe has turned
to Elf on the Shelf to bring in the
laughs every evening the American woman
was committed to outdoing herself with a
new setup one day she left the elf in a
pair of underwear stuck to the fridge
the next uh the elf cut up her kids
t-shirts in a cheeky prank so on the
sixth day of the tradition she had an
idea to outdo them all in the now viral
clip she shared her Creative Vision And
it left people stunned and feeling
disgusted standing in the bathroom CeCe
ran the bath and held out a plastic bag
inside was a school of tiny goldfish
swimming rapidly inside a bursting and
bursting to get free with the help of
her husband they cut open the bag
emptied the fish into the
bathtub um and then uh and then they set
up the elf like the elf was fishing and
there was a sign that said don't mind me
Just
Fishing and that was the setup anyway
people are upset and outraged and
they're saying it's animal
abuse abusing the the Goldfish or
whatever uh I think we have that video
here it is we'll watch a little bit I
don't know
[Music]
why
all right okay let's see how did you
really need three p did you need three
hands to open up to hold the bag of
goldfish um now look I know that you all
are probably
expecting that I will have a really
cynical and negative take on the Elf on
the Shelf
thing and you're right because I do uh I
hate it so
much I don't care about the Goldfish I'm
not offended by that particular example
of the alha the shelting uh in general I
hate it I I hate it I don't think I hate
I might hate it more than I hate
anything on Earth at this point now
granted I have a personal Grudge because
you know you have to understand six
kids right and you might think oh okay
you have six kids you must have one elf
for all the kids to
share one elf that moves around every
night and all the kids share in the
wonder and marment and all the kids say
look our one elf has
moved
amazing nope not in my house that's not
how we do things in my house we have six
elves six elves each kid gets their own
elf that's what was decided I didn't
decide it but it was decided and so
every night six elves have to move
six and the thing is you know here's
what I thought I thought well at least
some of our kids are getting older uh
and and the kids will age out of this
elf thing and then and so then we could
start pairing it down a little bit nope
wrong again because our oldest two they
don't even believe in the elf thing
anymore and they they know what's up
they still have an
elf so because you know and our youngest
two are babies and they don't understand
they have Elf also so we have six elves
and no actually we have more than six
because we also have um the elf some of
the elves have pets did you know that
was a thing a couple of the elves have
like
dogs so we you move the the elf and the
elf
dog are you one of the millions of
American men and women dealing with
premature hair loss maybe you're scared
about inheriting that thinning look
because it runs in the family well
there's a real solution that delivers on
its promises without the harsh side
effects unwanted chemicals or a need for
a prescription provia uses a safe
natural ingredient called proapple to
effectively Target the three main
ingredients of premature hair thinning
and loss provia delivers nourishing
nutrients to support healthy scalp
circulation and stronger hair follicles
provia guarantees more hair on your head
than in the shower or on your comb
effective for men and women of any age
provia safe on colored treated and
styled hair right now new customers save
over 50% plus free shipping on provia
introductory package at provia
hair.com Walsh every package includes a
full 60-day supply of provia serum for
daily use plus the provia super
concentrate for faster more noticeable
results every order includes uh your
choice of a free gift right now provia
works guaranteed or 100% of your money
back don't wait order now and save an
extra 10% off just in time for the
holidays at provia.com Walsh it's
provia.com
Walsh and here's a problem with the Elf
on the
Shelf the first few nights parents have
fun with it right they're on night six
and they're doing the Goldfish where do
you go from there what what's your plan
next it's like you're one up every night
it's more elaborate and then what when
you get to night eight it's you're gonna
have a drop off no you got to keep
getting more but it's it's it's it it
has to end
somewhere and so the first few nights a
parents have fun with it some of them do
but then quickly it becomes a chore it's
like this chore you have to do every
single night and uh and you know my my
wife now at night she's like oh man I
have to move the elves
again and I'm like no you don't you
don't have to this is not this is not a
a thing we had to add to our lives you
could just not do it we could be free of
this this totally useless and pointless
chore that we have complicated our lives
with for no
reason but it gets better because the
kids are really excited about the elves
every morning so that means that they
wake
up at the crack of dawn every morning in
December to come down and see where
their elves move
to now when I was a kid my parents had
to deal with that with the kids waking
up excited at the You Know Before Dawn
one morning in December on December
25th we do it every morning for the
entire
month and now we're stuck because once
you get into it you can't get out you're
like it's like it's like making a deal
with a drug cartel or something it's
like it's like borrowing money from the
mob because once you're in it you can't
get out because then and when I've
talked to my I said well let's let's
just not do the elves this year and then
I'm told well we can't we can't not do
the elves because then we're going to
have to tell the kids what are we going
tell the kids that the elves ran away
they they were abandoned by their
elves like the elves are magical they
just show up that's the whole deal so
how do we explain to them if the elves
don't show up do the elves hate them did
they do something
wrong what do we say to them well I know
what I would say I would just say listen
kids the elves aren't real come on like
obviously these are
toys that's what I would say but we
can't say that
so uh this is what our lives become for
all the it's it's not even Christmas
anymore it's it is the elf month the
whole the elf takes over the whole
thing I'm not bitter about
it I'm a little bitter hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see
there